a lead judge for so many years for
Strictly Come Dancing Len godman has
died at the age of
78 from bone cancer is what we're
hearing much love Strictly Come Dancing
judge he had been in a hospice I'm told
in Tunbridge Wells in Kent following a
short illness we're told by his
representative that he passed away on
Saturday night a spokesman for Len has
actually been speaking to mail online
saying I can confirm he died peacefully
over the weekend surrounded by his
family the former judge of Strictly Come
Dancing he was there from its launch
remember back in 2004 it's almost 20
years ago until 2016 hugely popular with
fans for his knowledge also for his
right humor and so many of us remember
how he used to say the number seven when
he was handing out scores to those that
were taking part as well as quickly also
appeared on the US version of the show
Dancing with the Stars that was from
2005 until 2022
in December he revealed he spends his
Saturday watching since retiring as
shouting the TV while watching strictly
is how he referred to that
Len as I said died in a hospice in
Tunbridge Wells after his short illness
born in
1944 started dancing at the age of 20.
after his doctors recommended it
following a foot injury the tragic news
I have to bring you this morning and so
many of us will recognize that face
instantly that's Len Goodman sadly he
has died at the age of 78 after a short
illness